thanks for having me so despite sorry
despite the hard situation I'm very
happy to be able to give these remote
presentations so the title of the
session is Java and the 40 version the
thing is that more and more I realized
that given we have accelerated the
currents of the Java release people are
are somehow confused about what's in
Java so today what I want to share with
you is basically what features will be
added in 2020 into Java platform why why
40 well I'm french-speaking and I always
confuse 40 and 14 so given that we have
just really in a version 14 of Java this
is really what I'm going to talk today
having said that I will also discuss
about Java 15 which is which will come
later this year in 2020 so this is a
standard server this camera from Oracle
don't make any process decision based on
what I will say today
having said that everything is open
source so we are good on that side the
only thing that you should you should
keep in mind is that and if anything
that I said about Java 15 can in theory
still change I mean Joe 18 will be
released in September so between now and
then there might be change that's
something that you have to keep in mind
about this disclaimer okay
may is a very important month because we
are about to celebrate the 25th
anniversary of Java so Java has been
released the first release has been
released 25 years ago so we were just
about to celebrate that year anniversary
the thing is that Java keep evolving
since 25 years based on two core
principle the first one developer
productivity second core principle is
application performance this has been
done through the last 25 years in the
face of constantly evolving things such
as program programming predicts for
example 25 20 years ago we're not really
talking about any kind of functional
programming when it was when it when
were talking about Java that something
since then that has been become more and
more important something else that
evolved is application style in the
beginning we were mainly talking about
client-server application we're talking
about Minnelli's application those day
obviously it's more and more about micro
services so this is yet another
evolution that Java has to cope with
deployment styles in the early days we
were deploying in our own data center on
lots of those day we tend to deploy
using containers in the cloud so that's
another big shift when it comes to to
the way we deploy our application and
again Java has to cope with that and
last but not least obviously the other
one is evolving so those de for example
we have more and more course in our
machines we have more and more memory we
have vector support directly built into
general-purpose computers we have
multiple level cache when it comes to
memory and so on and so on
so does Blas this is basically out of a
divorce for the last 25 years and this
is how it will continue to evolve so
this is a pretty busy slide I'm not
gonna spend time on this slide this
slide basically lists all the features
that were added in Java 9 and Java 9 was
a special release in the sense that it
was the latest large release of Java and
there's a big issue with that so every
two to three years we were releasing one
Java version with a bunch of features so
when it comes to adopting those features
it was very difficult because the
developers basically had a horror of a
sudden access to a bunch of features so
getting a getting familiar with those
features was very difficult so we
decided to change the way Java is
evolving so now it works this is
something that we have put in place end
of 2017 so every six months does there
is a new a Java release so it's called
it's called a feature release so 11 12
13
the current Java release is 14
in March and in September 2020 we're
gonna release 15 that's a given
six months later sixteen and so on and
so on
now all those future release are open
source and are supported until the next
release comes out so nine was supported
at least until ten cans out and so on
and so on so that means that today 14
will be our at least supported and until
15 comes out and 115 will be released in
September the current release will be 15
and that does it Lee if you're in the
open source side you should use that
version because that's the that's the
version that is supported now we also
acknowledge that there are some user
typically enterprise they are not able
to move that rapidly so moving for 14 to
15 is in itself not a big work given
that they are not demanding that many
features between all those beliefs but
still there are people there there are
some type of user that prefer to stick
to one release for many many years so
that's what that's why we are tracker I
have decided to have long-term support
release so basically a long-term
supporter is is nothing more than a
given future release that we take and we
maintain for a very very long time
eleven is the current LTS the next one
will be seventeen so those release would
be supportive supported for many many
years despite the fact that obviously we
will still have every six months and new
features release so basically it
provides choice either you use the open
JDK build that Oracle is providing they
are free the only thing is that if you
are using those bills well you'd better
keep with the Java release guidance
so right now ideally you want to be on
14 because this is the Reese that is
supported and that's also the raise that
is getting the security updates if you
are not able to move that quickly Oracle
also sells support for Java that's the
Oracle JDK so when it comes to buying
Oracle support there are two things that
you should look at the price of that
support
honestly the price of the Oracle support
for Java is pretty cheap but I will let
you judge that the only thing that you
need to look at when you decide where
you want to get your support for Java is
basically the ability that the
organization you are looking at is able
to support you and this slide shows the
number of issue that were fixed in in
this particular example in GDG 14 and we
see that Oracle is clearly the company
that contributes the most to Java so the
takeaway here Java is still free dr bean
there has been a lot of countries and
conclusions regarding that but Java is
and remains free so now let's quickly
discuss about how can we enable faster
innovation within the platform so the
first thing that we put in place two or
three years ago was this new release
guidance where every six months we have
a new release we also have the just the
jep's
mechanism so chip stands for jdk enhance
enhancements proposal so it's basically
a mechanism that we use to introduce in
the platform new java language features
new GDK features or even we're using
that process to remove things from the
platform or we are also using that
features for example to evolve how the
open to open JDK project is managed so
it's basically some kind of lightweight
mechanism that Lily that is clearly
documented and tell the community how
things are supposed to work when it
comes to doing something non-trivial
non-trivial in the into the platform
next to that we have also put in place
multiple feedback feedback mechanism
that we are using to get feedback on non
final features so the thing is that
whenever we put something into the
platform as soon as it's final it's
something that is there forever so it's
basically it becomes permanent
so we'd better get it right before we
turn something into a permanent feature
within the platform so for that we have
multiple mechanism that we can use to
basically give to developers non final
features we encourage developer to used
on those non final feature
and based on the feedback we can still
do adjustments to those features before
we make them permanent so we have the
preview features mechanism which is used
more for language Java language features
we also have experimental features which
we use mainly for odd spot VM features
and then we have an additional feature
sorry additional mechanisms such as
encoder modules early GDK access built
that we use to basically give access to
to prototype of new capabilities that we
are thinking of adding into the platform
and last but not least we have an
ongoing open JDK project that his name
is Caruso the the goal of SCARA
is to investigate alternative to
mercurial so if you are looking if you
know open JDK you know that for many
years open JDK when in fact since the
beginning open JDK as used a material as
is as its source code management
solution it worked for many years but
honestly material is a bit tough to
learn so if you want to encourage more
contributions well we'd better look at
alternative so that was the goal of that
project look at our alternatives and the
outcome is
skaara selected get as the alternative
so that means that all the open JDK
development is moving to get SCARA has
also looked at hosted get providers
github has been selected but Kelly
skaara and open JDK is not tied to a get
up so if something goes wrong with
github we can easily switch despite the
size of the project where different gate
providers and last but not least Kara's
also looked at how we can improve the
complete development lifecycle of open
JDK by adding on top of it some
additional two links so a bunch of open
JDK project I've already moved to github
we have the list here amber SCARA GMC
lumen so on and so on and all the rest
obviously are planned to move in fact we
plan to move GDK itself
hater around I think end of GDK 15 so
that would be still in 2020
or around early 16 so still in 2020 but
still all the projects are ridden I've
read only a mirror on the tabs so
basically all those all those bullets
won't give us the ability to enable
faster innovation within the platform
something that we have already used and
we clearly see the benefit of all of
those tools sorry
so delivering faster so we have enabled
the ability to deliver to deliver faster
and well let's look at what we have
deliver recently when I say we it's
really open JDK community obviously
Oracle is a big player in that community
but it's not just a rival right
so Java 10 delivering in March 2018
those are all the features I'm not going
to spend any time on those release
because we already have enough to cover
with a 14 and 15 the only thing is that
you might seem that we have two chips
that are in kind of yellow orange color
those have been delivered by someone
else than Oracle so the one in blacks
are coming from Oracle and the other one
are coming from other open JDK members
and I believe those two are coming from
reddit then we had 11 which was a pretty
big release in terms of capability the
thing to keep in mind is that any
features release is driven by the dates
so it's either March or September's they
are not driven by features so if if a
feature is not ready to be included in a
given feature release well it's not an
issue that features will just have to
wait the next feature release 12 March
29 13 September 20 1913 was clearly a
relatively small release but yeah anyway
14 that was released two months ago
basically well cope with the fact that
13 was really modest but again the only
thing that it tried those release is the
due dates not the content so today we're
gonna discuss us some of those jabs
I've been headed in a Java 14 again we
see that there are two jets coming from
nonno that are not coming from Oracle
non-volatile byte buffer I think is
coming from reddit and helpful point of
exception that we're gonna discuss later
is coming from sa P okay so Java 14 was
released in March 2020
everything is open source so GD k dot
java.net / 14 you can have access to the
open JDK Bills of 14 you can also have
access to all the technical content
regarding that release now quickly Java
15 what do we know about Java 15 well
first and foremost we know that Java 15
will be released in September 2020 we
also know the schedule so we know that
random phase 1 that's basically when we
have the feature freeze is in one month
from now
so 1111 of of June so today
based on the information that is
available in the open JDK project we can
already discuss about what's being
planned within 15 that's what I'm gonna
do today now keep in mind that things
can obviously still change we can add
things at the very last minute or we can
even drop things at the very last minute
depending on well on some stability
issue or something else
things can might still evolve so those
tunings basically gives you the content
that is plain for 14 so we clearly well
it's a very interesting time for Java
because we clearly have a very rich
pipeline when it comes to features why
because my well quite as well I wouldn't
say many years ago but five to four
years ago we have decided to work on
very ambitious project multiple project
that where long terms are in the project
and they each had a goal to basically
either fundamentally improve certain
aspects of the Java block
or event we've revamped a given aspect
of the platform so I'm going to discuss
some of those today zgc amber panama
Varela metropolis loom and so on so very
quickly the first one that I want to
discuss is the GC 0 GC so it's loaded
and C scalable garbage collector that we
started to work on few years ago it was
introduced as a experimental features in
Java 11 and the main goal of the GC is
basically gives you the lowest latency
possible so it's a concurrent GC meaning
that all the heavy lifting work of the
GC is done basically while your Java
threads are being executed so there are
a few posts but they are reduced to
about well to the smallest possible to
the smallest time possible we claim that
the post time should stay below 10
milliseconds we don't with the GC but
what we observe is that most of the time
the poles are more around 20 seconds
which obviously is very low
it's callable in the sense that the post
time will not increase as you grow your
app or your life sets so the 10
millisecond post time is something that
you would get typically on a one
gigabyte eep but also on a one terabyte
if so there's no change in that front
the G's in the in the early days was
designed for large ships multi terabyte
if but it turns out that the our use
case where it also makes sense to use
the GC for smaller heaps
so one of the features that we have
added recently is the support for a few
megabytes oops I think that the law was
that we can go is 8 megabytes so how do
you use as a GC today so I mentioned
that the GC was added as an experimental
feature in a Java 11 so you need to
unlock explicitly the GC
so there is a specific hot spot flag
unlock experimental a vm option to
basically unlock any experimental
feature of the vm so you do that and
then you use the specific flag to enable
the GC so basically to tell the VM to
switch from g1 which is the default DC
to z GC and there we go then the thing
that you might want to do is tune the GC
to tune the z GC the thing that you need
to do basically is just said the if size
one of the design goal of the GC was
also to provide a default behavior that
avoid any tunings obviously you still
have the ability to do more tuning than
just setting the heap size but by
default the GC should should give you a
good result with just setting the
website so said you see what is the
history behind the GC GC was initially
introduced in 11 as an experimental
features on Linux we have hadded
additional capabilities in 12 intersted
the GC support was added for arm 64 and
finally in 14 so the reason that we have
done two months ago is having support
for Mac OS and windows for the GC and
the plan is to make the GC as a
production feature so basically we are
removing that experimental flag from the
feature in DD give 15 so this year so
this is a picture that I took early
earlier this year in sweden and on stage
was Monica Beckwith from Microsoft and
well that's her claim it's not my claim
so zgc shine when it comes to
responsiveness so I encourage you to
check her presentation which is now
online where she goes basically about
the benefit of the GC now let's quickly
talk about G 1 G C so G 1 GC is the
default GC obviously we have made a lot
of investment within the GC but that
doesn't mean that we are were not
looking at improving G 1 so for example
in 14 we had its support for Numa so you
must stand for non-uniform memory access
so basically that means that some some
memory might be
well the distance between the memory and
the course is not always equal so from
one cor accessing a given memory might
be more expensive because it's more
distant then accesses memory in a
different part of Lowell form from a
different course parallel GC was new
more worse since it's a long time so in
14 we have had it support Numa support
for g1 and that's not all if we look at
the number of an enhancement that we
have done in our on g1 since gk8 it's
over 700 announcements that together
greatly improve g1 so the shafts shows
for example so the shots below shows the
native memory overhead caused it but by
your g1 GC for a heap size of 6 16
gigabyte and what we can see is that
well if we look at GD k8 the extra
native memory was a run for megabyte in
11 it was around well it was below 3
sorry I said megabyte it's gigabyte so
it 8 need an additional 4 gigabyte 2 GC
that large EEP GDK 11 it was reduced to
I think 2.7 gigabyte and in 14 it's it
has been reduced to 1.7 gigabyte so
basically you see that by switching from
8 to 14 we have greatly reduce the
memory footprint of g1 not only that we
also improve the performance so
basically when you put together all
those heaven and reading enhancements
that improves g1 a lot across all areas
so throughput footprint latency and so
on and so on
so that's something that you you need to
consider if obviously GC well the GC GC
characteristic azzam are important to
you you need to think about moving to a
newer version of the of the platform
so this is another chart that shows some
of the management that have been done to
g1 so let's see this is using the
standard spec gbb benchmark so this one
is using a fix it fix hip so set to four
gigabyte all the results are normalized
and I her is better so we have maxed G
opps and quick LG UPS both are looking
at the throughput the thing is that
quick LG G UPS is looking in addition to
throughput is also looking at latencies
so we can see that parallel GC has been
in so the performance of our LG C has
been increased between 8 and 14 but we
can also see that there is a huge boost
in terms of latency improvement when it
comes to G 1 in 14 having said that if
we look sorry at this slide at the next
slides with C in this particular case so
this is whether with the hip of 16 GB
gigabyte that there has been a
regression between 8 well we I don't
have the result of G 1 here but we can
clearly see that there is a drop so we
had a regression basically and I don't
remember the exact issue if you want to
know more about the the given bug it's
you just need to check the blocks at the
bottom of the slides but that issue has
been solved so we can clearly see that G
1 in 15 will improve the latencies we
see that the throughput is is while
there is a slight drop in terms of
throughput only 97 percent versus hungry
percent well it's a small it's a small
basically small trade-off but when we
see the benefit that gives that it gives
in terms of 11 see improvement I think
that it's fair to say that it's okay to
pay that that's more price so
quickly stuffed up time is something
that we always look to improving all the
Java release and obviously 14 is not is
not an exception now we can see in this
case that the stuff that time for a
given it's a small application it's
basically a HelloWorld application there
is a small improvement
obviously the as faster we get the more
difficult it is to find large
improvement but still between 13 and 14
the startup time has been improved and I
can already tell you that between 14 and
15 it we still slightly improved now
this is basically the same benchmark but
with different scenarios so a hello
world application a hello world
application that uses a lambda
expression and then a hello world
application that is using a Concord
string I think then you basically seen
that across all the release we are
improving the startup time for those
different scenario so that's something
that again is useful over time whenever
you switch to a larger to a newer
version of Java so now let's talk so we
have discussed about the GC which which
is one of that those ambitious project
basically having a new garbage
collectors that provide low latency
another one that deal with memory is
project Valhalla and that that is a
clearly very ambitious project so the
code of general of Valhalla is basically
to reboot the relationship that the JVM
as with the data in memory so if you
know Java you know that Java is very
good at optimizing code we have for
example a JIT compiler that will improve
over time your code add as it runs so on
that side we're good but the next step
is we to look on how we can optimize a
data in memory now there's an issue we
have to judge the Java type systems
something that obviously is very
powerful but there is a price price to
pay and sometimes we miss a bit of
flexibility and that's basically due to
the fact that each object has an
identity it's something that obviously
is needed we are not going to get
field of object identity it enables
mobility polymorphism and so on and so
on on the other hand there are some use
case where objects might not need
identity but still today they have to
pay the price for that features even
though those object might not benefit
from identity
so basically project Valhalla is looking
at how we can improve the density of
information within memory and the thing
that the team is looking at is basically
how we can declaratively say that okay
for that type of object I don't need
that object to handle an identity it's
not something that can be done
automatically so that we involve some
help from the developers so the
developer will have to specifically say
oh specifically say okay for that type
of object I don't need identity and then
the VM will be able to improve out those
object would be stored into memory and
the VM will be able to increase the
density the in memory density for those
type of objects another project is
projecting so if you look today they are
well I will simplify a little bit but
there are two types of programming
approach so you have a traditional
blocking approach so it's very easy to
program to develop with the thing is
that well it's so it's very easy to
develop it's also very easy to debug the
thing is that that approach doesn't
scale as soon as your code blocks
well basically your code is waiting for
something to happen so you are using
while you are blocking resources that's
not very effective on the other hand you
can go for a model that is more geared
towards a reactive approach the thing is
that developing reactive application
well that's on one hand a very difficult
model to program with and more
importantly that the code you write is
very difficult to debug enhance to
maintain typically if you try to debug a
reactive application while you
see that something you have an issue
here but in fact the issue is not really
happening on that well in that vision of
the application but it's happened some
for somewhere else but it's very
basically it's very difficult to do
correlation between an issue and where
it happened within the flow of the code
but still if you want to scale if you
want to have an efficient resource use
of you you need to go to other approach
that approach so a project loom is
basically trying to solve that by making
concurrency simple again ow
right now the JVM is using native
threads kernel threads loom introduced
the notion of your 12 threads which are
basically two threads that are managed
by the JVM so those threads are some
kind of well visual threads software
threads that are managed and fiddled by
the JVM and obviously the JVM will have
to do mapping between those virtual
thread and some underlying kernel
carrier thread but that that isn't
dulled by the JVM and the thing is that
those virtual threads are very very
cheap so it doesn't it's not a really an
issue to write code that is looking
because the virtual thread that is
blocking is not blocking an actual
underlying physical threads so basically
you can write application using virtual
thread your code can blocks but you
don't have to pay of resource under
virtualization so those that are so
cheap that it well you don't even you
don't even have to pull those threads so
you just block the thread and you you
start a new thread it's it's it's it's
not an issue because the photographer
chip so that's basically what a loom is
trying to solved now those days we have
multiple early access build of loom if
we look in the platform there are
already a few gems that are been that
have been added in the platform for loom
and more specifically in GDK 14 we have
we have hope we implemented the legacy
zakat API that was something in
preparation for something that's coming
in JDK 15 which is a remem
the legacy that as a group that diagram
socket API which has been done in
preparation of loom so another large
project is paramah so the goal of Panama
is basically to arrange to enrich the
interaction between the java virtual
machine and foreign native code
historically we had gni for that Java
native interface but gni has been
specifically designed in the early days
to be I would say not friendly to use we
want to basically provide an alternative
to Genie I wear it is easy safe and
efficient to use from Java native to use
native code from Java if you look at the
deliverables of Panama
there are three main deliverables the
foreign memory access API which is in 14
in incubator so that's something that
you can use already today
it basically allowed to efficiently and
safely use of memory of that is not on
the Java EEP but you can access that
memory from Java code then there is an
extraction part it's basically the
ability to extract from C native header
files so extract interface and generate
binders that you can use directly from
Java code there are two part for the
extraction parts that there is a tool
that mimic that mechanically do the
extraction but also no API that more
advanced developer can use to meet more
than scenarios and last but not least
there's the vector API which allows to
easily express vector computation that
will compile at runtime and execute on
the tour on CPU that support vector
vectorize extension such as SSE or AVX
4md your arms scalable vector extension
and the Victoria PI is right now in
incubator candidate so we don't know yay
yet in which
GDK rule is it will be headed
so today what we have for loom is the
foreign memory access API in the
incubator that's something that you can
use and we also have an early access
build for the extraction part and then I
also put this in the Panama part even
though that specific [ __ ] is not really
part of Panama but given that it's very
close to the hardware and well I put it
here so jet 3-5-2 basically had the
ability to manage non-volatile memory
via byte buffer that's something very
specific so I'm not going to discuss
about that anymore so what I'm gonna do
now is a very small Panama demo so it
takes a bit of time to switch ok so
let's see so I hope that it's big enough
so whatever here I have a very simple
java application but first I'm gonna go
let's see where is it no so I'm on OS 6
this is a Linux so I sign in Linux no I
don't want to do that well I fit the
name sorry let me check ok is this or
sorry too small you know it's red line
so this is a header file that is part of
of way 6 so this is a real line library
that basically give us read line support
something very basic so there are
multiple function and what I want to do
here is you use one of the one of the
red line function from Java so the first
thing that I need to do is use the
extract tool to basically parse the red
line header files to extract all the
information and then generate the binder
interface for that
so I'm gonna use this extract tool so
and I specify here that this is the past
for example of the library the G the
redline library this is the path of the
header file that we want to x-rayed and
what I want is that I want the outcome
to be in that a jar file obviously I'm
not on the right version so let's see
I'm on 14 and I'm need to switch G so
I'm going to switch to a specific GDK
build that support panama and it's 14 I
think whoops Rama yes
so let's invoke Jicks track g extract
again
okay bunch of warning but this is an
early access build okay now I have this
jar that has been generated so what I
want to do is basically I have this
small java application we can very
quickly go over the code of that
application so a scope is something that
is provided by the foreign memory yes
the foreign memory api of panama and
basically scope are used to enforce
lightness checks on scope resources so
it's basically some sort of memory but
that we will allocate on the other side
so on the native side we need to enforce
likeness because whenever we are located
on the other side of the fence so on the
native side obviously at some point in
time what has been allocated needs to be
de-allocated so that's why we need scope
so I create a scope then from that scope
has I allocate a string I pass it I pass
in the screen name so we're on the on
the sea side and then I'm just invoking
that function that is coming from the
redline library using this pointer that
is defined here so basically I'm just
passing this string to the native
function and what we get in return is a
P object which is a pointer and then I'm
just deploying displaying
objects so this is a two string method
invocation on the P so on the pointer
object and then I use this static method
to basically get the content of that
pointer so let's compile that so Java C
let's see class bus I specify the jar
red line and then the source okay now I
need to run that that guy so name so
this is a basically this line here where
we invoke the red line so this is the CE
OS six function that is invoke I pass
it's something test and then the result
is the following so it's a so the type
is a bomb in pointer so this is this
line in fact to string on that P object
which is a pointer and then so this is
all the result of the two string
information all the information that we
get the idea to string and then the last
thing is this test which is basically we
ask the foreign memory API to give us
the content that is pointed on the other
side of the fence but by that given
pointer so this is in a nutshell how
panama works so if you if you have any
question you can use the chat or we can
discuss at the end it's up to you so
moving on another big project is a
project number so the goal of amber is
basically to continue continuously
improve developer productivity through
the evolution of the java language so
it's not something that happened through
one single release it's something that
we have started around a Java 10 and
since Java 10 we have hadded new
features which are basically emerging
from project amber var is a big one so
variable type inference was added in 10
in 14
Herring's which expression it becomes a
standard features after to run off
preview we're doing another round of
preview for text blocks we are
introducing record we're in show
introducing also pattern matching with
instance of in preview too so I'm going
to discuss most of those features so the
first one is a record so records
basically give you the ability to so
they are providing a very compact syntax
for declaring class which are data
holder so basically a triple inimitable
double in which you can store data and
that's something that you can basically
pass around I'm going to show you how it
works so you will see that well it's
something that is a on one hand very
simple but on your hand very efficient
something else that is coming from amber
is a text blocks
so basically text blocks are multi-line
string literals so take the following
example so you want to store the HTML
that we have on the left side typically
you would do something in your code with
text blocks you can now do that so you
basically keep the Descent acts as it is
you don't have to escape anything it's
something which is very convenient for
dealing with XML JSON UML SQL and so on
again that's something that we will see
in a demo in a minute so then we have a
pattern matching that's something that
we will see in the demo it will be more
clear and finally we have a new switch
expression so let's go to the demo that
will be a more concrete so let's see
well intelligence already started so I'm
going to very quickly create a new
project
I need to configure my compiler because
I don't know why but by default generate
Java c5 bytecode and then I also need to
configure my project and I'm gonna
increase the font for the code don't
worry
so here given that I'm gonna use ah
sorry it's not here it's here given that
I'm going to use some preview feature I
need to ask specifically tell to
IntelliJ that I want to use preview
features because preview features are
not enabled by default and I also need
to do it let's see here so again I'm
going to use 14 preview features okay so
uh source ok so let's just run that and
see if it works ok it works
so the first thing that I'm going to
show you is recourse so let's create a
record let's say that we want to create
a record for a person and a person as a
name and a person as a first name and
that's it it's all we have to do now
what I can do in my code is the
following for example so I can create a
record and today speakers is the let us
say the read oops
oops sorry it's obviously not a record
but a person okay so now I have this
speaker object that I can use so for
example a speaker so let's run that so
this is the result so this is basically
the to do tutoring method that is invoke
ated on that speaker object so let's
have a look at what has been what we are
here so target class we should have two
class so we have the test class and we
have this person claps so this is our
record so if we look at the record
itself so just by this simple
declaration we see that we have a few
methods that have been generated so
generated so the class person is final
it extends java.lang records it has a
few methods so it has a constructor it
has a two string it has a it has a
default Ascot methods it has an equals
and then it has two gathers last and
first name so that means that I can for
example invoke one of those and we use
one of those method and you see that
this time we have the let us say instead
of the two string so what we can do if
you look at the record itself obviously
this is the default behavior
I haven't specified anything I can
define my own constructor so person I
can say for example that let's see we
want to uppercase all the names right so
let's run that
so you see that oops
the lab assay is now in upper case and
you see that the only thing I had to do
is basically I had just have to specify
what needs to be done with one of the
the field I didn't have to specify
anything for the first field so it has
the default behavior but now if I'm
doing something like this for example if
let's see last is blank then this last
equal nemours here the compiler will
complain because last might not have
been initialized so if we go through
this branch of course last easy last is
initialized but that means that we if we
have a else it won't be so if last name
is not blank it won't be initialized so
to solve that basically we need two
other in this case a house and so else
this last fall's
last in this case we have a default for
second branch and this case it it works
so if I have a blanks let's run that and
you see that this time oops sorry
it's the first time is an animal's
because it is blank so that's basically
our record works
the next thing text blocks so let's see
for that I'm gonna yes so this is the my
the poem that has been generated so it's
just some XML so it's the pump from my
project and well I want to create a
string for that so for that I'm going to
use a text block so for that I'm used a
triple quotes
and that's all it takes now I can do so
pom South if I run that well you see
that the text blocks has been is
correctly including the ident a shame
because here I'm basically copy the HTML
as it was so what up what I've done here
is basically I kept orientation but we
will see we probably don't want to have
although space in front that's something
that takes blog handles for us something
else that we can do is for example the
following with text blogs so they're not
able to able to evaluate expression but
well let's just do that
so how did a person has here and now I
can use formatted and let's see and what
I want here is the speaker first for
example so let's run that lips sorry
typo it's a method so if you look at the
HTML you we see that he well it's not
class but it's the first name but you
get the idea so basically we can do some
kind of cheap expression interpolation
using formatted with text blocks so
that's basically our text works text
blocks works now let's move on to
another features of number and that's
let's pattern matching so pattern
matching so you see we have this speaker
object which in fact is a person so that
means that we can do something like
speaker first
right so we would get David but it might
happen that the type of that object is
of that yes of that speaker would be
object in that case if you see we cannot
directly invoke the the first method so
what we would typically do is something
like this so if speaker instance of it's
a person so if it's a person then what
we do we create a new object so it's a
person object X equal to a speaker but
we have to specific just it to a person
type and here obviously we want to use
the subject so that works so the thing
is that here you see that if we have
this type we create an object of that
same type and we cast it from the other
object using that same type there are a
lot of repetition going on what we can
do now with pattern matching instance of
energy TK 14 is the following so we
declare the new variable here and that's
it so if you run this will get the exact
the exact same behavior
so hello dahveed this is the first one
and hello david this is the second one
and you see that this one is more 6n so
it's more obvious to use so the last one
and I'm probably gonna skip that one
because it takes a bit of time is the
future expression so it's a new type of
switch expression that works like this
so this is on the left side this is how
it traditional works the thing attacked
for example here there's a bug in the
sense that there is no break here so if
I do a switch on let's say Friday well
number of character will be 6 and then
it would be 7 so that would be the end
result 7 in this case I'm doing a switch
over an enumeration so all the values
are no because
animation but still if I miss for
example one of the day the compiler will
not be able to tell me okay you are not
evaluating windows day for example so
that's why we have a default but given
that we know all the value the default
is a bit well it's a bit hot to have to
use a default value so what we can do
now there is a question we will we be
able to use recorded GBA GP entities not
directly something that well you can use
records with GPA but the thing that you
have to keep in mind is that records are
immutable so you cannot change with any
fills as soon as it has been created so
let's go back to these to the switch
expression this is the new switch
expression it basically returns the
value directly so something we were not
able to do in the former switch
expression so that well that's why this
is on the left side the switch statement
and this is an expression because it
pretends the value so we have all the
case given that again we are doing a
case on enumeration the compiler will
test tell us if if for example we're
missing a day so if we're missing a day
either we had this day or we have to
deal with the default value if we are
dealing with all the days and if we have
a default value the default will never
be rich so that's something that the
compiler can can also infer that the
default branch will is basically a dead
branch those kind of things so that's in
a nutshell the switch expression so I'm
going to move a little bit because I'm a
bit ahead of time I'm sorry shouldn't my
bad I switch the slide I should bring
switch moved out of the slides so the
amber demo we have seen the amber demo
so those are some of the project that
the more ambitious long-term project
that we are working on what we see that
gradually some of the features emerging
from those project are headed in Java so
we've seen the foreign memory coming
from loom for exam
we've seen alhambra has added multiple
features or since Java 10 in the Java
platform but obviously the Java platform
is not all about huge an ambitious
project in 14 we have this new elf full
new pointer exception jab 3 5 8 so we
have whole scene seen that kind of code
where we basically have a new pointers
so it's not a big deal because the we
know where the new point shows happened
so line 6 6 6 so we just have to look at
that line right the thing is that line
might looks like the following so we
know that it's happened here but we
really have no idea where it happened
exactly that's what the new pointers the
helpful with pointers option give us so
that's something that you have to
explicitly enable in 14 and now you will
have something like this so it cannot
involve the city get district because
the return value of get city is null so
it basically gives us more information
to help us to pinpoint the exact issue
that's raised that new pointers so
that's something that is available as a
standard feature in 14 if not in
available enabled by default and I've
seen some discussion where in 15 it
might be enabled by default so it so
it's a small features but it's a very
convenient features JDK flight recorder
is something that is available I think
since Java 11 and the basic idea of JDK
of flight recorder GFR it's a black box
that keeps track of even that are
emitted by different component within
the GDK itself so it can be the the JVM
it can be your code so a bunch of
heavens are raised and GFR will keep
track of them and that's something that
you can use after the fact to do some
kind of analysis the thing is that GFR
is very low overhead so that's something
that you can use in production to
basically detect and pinpoint specific
issue something that we're hiring in
GDK 14 is even swimming so until now the
the way you were using GFR was the
following so you start the recording
your application so you use your
application then you stop the recording
you dub the content of the event to
repository and then you process those
events now an application that is
running as the ability to stream out
event as they happen so you can
basically do is you can have some some
some coughs some some sort of sidecar
application to do analysis of the event
as they happen so there is a specific
API to do that in GDK 14 the thing is
that obviously we're keeping we are
improving a GFR through all the release
so in 14 we are we add hundred and
forty-five different event types for GFR
and in 15 I've checked in delayed well
it's not the latest build because we
have done at twenty to build yesterday
but in the middle of last week we are we
had hundred and fifty seven GFR even
type so it keeps GFR it in itself keeps
to have more matrix within the platform
that you can use and not only that you
can also write your own custom and even
type for your application something else
that is part of Gd k14 is this new
packaging tool
Jib Jab 343 right now it's still in an
equation phase so the idea of that tool
is it's a tool that gives you the
ability to create native installer
specific for a given platform so on
Windows you will either have an MSI or
an exit file on my quest you will have a
big package file or a dmg and so on and
so on and it has a lot of additional I
would say native features such as the
ability to pass parameters to the native
executable that will invoke that will do
the installation of your java
application obviously work with jailings
and so on and so on so that's something
that you can use today to basically
create native installer for your java
code now let's quickly look at java 15
so that's the schedule nothing will
change on that front
so this is a table that I did well I did
it yesterday and I checked this morning
it was still up to date so those are the
multiple job that will be part of 15 I'm
going to discuss specifically to Jeb's
that is a hidden class and where it's
you're the one I'll seal the silk type
seal class it's not here now I don't so
yeah I miss one well anyway it's on my
slide later on oh yes here sorry see the
other one is sealed class so so this
slide shows the jet that are either
integrated so already in the early build
of GDK 15 or they are targeted so then
sorry targeted means that we intend to
add them to 15 or we propose to target
them though so that's basically the
first step before we integrate them so
we tell the community okay we want to
add that to 15 is there any objection if
not we will if we move to to target it
and then one the works is done it will
move from targeted to integrated so
basically there is a very high chance
that all the Jets here will be part of
GDK 15 just keep in mind the small
disclaimer that we might find a big
issue in one of those one of the jab
here and we might decide to remove it at
the very last minute so that there's
always a risk and then there are a few
other jets that are currently being
worked on and we don't know yet if there
will be part of 15 so one is still class
and well there are a bunch of jet but I
just took three where clearly there are
a lot of activities going on right now
so maybe there will be part of 15 we
will see in a few weeks and at worst by
early June we will know for sure if they
are part of fifteen or not
so seal class throw in memory access a
new name incubator so that's part of
Project loon and then the vector API
which is also part of Project loon
so I'm going to very quickly discuss a
hidden class and a seal class which are
often confused so a hidden class is
something that is very specifically that
has been specifically done for
frameworks developers so if we cut
frameworks they have this habit of
dynamically generating classes and use
those classes through reflection the
thing is that those classes given that
they are generated can potentially be
used by a Hodder slash external byte
code something that we clearly don't
want so basically the ability of it edan
class give now frameworks developer the
ability to still generate dynamically
classes on the fly but those class are
hidden for the rest of the world so only
the framers that generate those class
will be able to use those classes so it
targets frameworks developers but if you
look at Java C for example Java sees
your show using the techniques for
example for lambda expression so that's
something that is also useful for Java
itself and one of the thing that will be
done in addition to creating this new
facility is also deprecating the Sun
Myshkin safe define animus classes that
is used exactly for doing that
dynamically generate generating classes
so if you look at the properties of
those classes well in terms of discovery
discoverability
they shouldn't be basically discoverable
discoverable by classes outside of the
classes that has created adult classes
in terms of life cycle it should those
classes should be able to be
aggressively unloaded to give the
framers the ability to generate a lot of
classes and as soon as those classes are
not needed they will be automatically
garbage collected now they can be
garbage collected through a more
traditional approach that's something
that is but the behavior of the GC is
configurable for hidden classes but what
we know for sure is that the aggressive
unloading is something that is needed
and then access control that basically
give us the ability forecast that
creates dynamically another
class to access that class but that also
prevent other classes external to that
classes to access that newly created
class so that's basically none shell
hidden classes it's not something that
you're gonna use that most of the
developers like you and me will use it's
clearly something for frameworks
developers and then they are Sid class
and some people tend to confuse the two
there are completely different so before
we talk about seed class we need to
quickly talk about inheritance so
inheritance is something that encourage
code reuse so we basically have a class
hierarchy and all the class for example
a class at X and the class can reuse
features from the class that it extends
for now the thing is that the class
hierarchy is most of the dwell is often
used for code reuse but sometimes it's
used for something completely different
so the class hierarchy is on is
sometimes also used to model different
possibility of a given gap of a given
domains so for example we want to model
the different shape that are supported
by a graphic application so we would
have a shape class or interface and then
we are have subclasses that would extend
that shape classes like a square
extended shapes on exactly on external
shapes and so on or we we can have a
class that representative type of
vehicles that we sell and then we would
have I don't know a CV a coupe sedan and
so on that extends that super classes so
that's a different something that is
completely different and the problem is
that right now if you have this shape
superclass that is extended by triangle
circle exact on and so on you cannot
prevent any other class to also extend
it and that's something that we would
like to well read with a sealed class so
C class would basically allows to have a
given class hierarchy that is bounded so
it the class hierarchy can only be
extended by class within that limited
closet class hierarchy and not by any
external classes and every cycle we use
would still be possible but it wouldn't
only be possible within domain within
the bound the boundary of the closet
class hierarchy so how does that work
well let's have a look at an example
that would be more abuse so I have this
shape superclass and we have two new
keywords so we have sealed that is used
to basically say okay the class shape is
sealed and then we have the permits
keyword that tells which class or
interface can use that superclass so
sealed is sorry shape is sealed and only
in this example circle circle rectangle
and square are allowed to extend those
shapes and then there are a few
variations like the flag the fact that
if you are within the same package or SM
modules you can just use the class name
you don't have to use the full package
name if you have nested class so all the
classes within a single file source you
just seal the superclass and by default
all the classes that are present in the
same source file will be permitted by
default to extend that soup superclass
so that's basically how it works now
it's not clear today if shield class
will be part of did he give 15 if not
that's not really an issue just mean
that we'll have to wait another six
months and it will be for gdf 16 so I
think it's time to wrap up so today
we've discussed about what new features
will be added to Java in 2020 so GDK 14
was released two months ago and JDK 15
will be raised in
four months from now I've also discussed
very quickly and out those large
ambitious long-term projects are
basically gradually adding capabilities
into the platform with the ultimate goal
goals of revamping completely the
platform now I need to quickly discuss
another new project that we've just
announced two weeks ago and that is
Laden so laden basically tried to solve
to tackle some of the pain points of
Java and that is the slow startup time
the slow time to performance and the
large footprint of the bob a java
application and everything is relative
when I say slow it's called slow
compared to typically native
applications for example footprints it's
again compared to native application so
basically Laden tried to tackle those
pain point by introducing the concept of
static image to Java something similar
to Ralphie on native image Laden aims to
leverage existing component of the GDK
such as hotspot GAE OTC which is an alt
compiler that we have an experimental
form since gk9 into the platform but
also CTS and gelling and clearly this is
just the early days of Lydon we have
just started to gather interest around
that project but we think that over time
this is something that would be
important so basically try bring the
capability that we have with native Miam
then similar capabilities but directly
into the Java platform so this is the
slides depict the content of GDK 14 I
think that we have discussed most of the
jobs that we have here the only thing
that I need to mention and I think I've
mentioned that at the beginning is that
jobs are are also used to remove hold or
things from the platform so you see that
for example 3 6 2 & 3 6 3 are
duplicating things from the platform and
or removing so when we remove something
from the platform we first deprecated to
tell the world that ok that features
will be removed in the features and then
later on it will be actually removed so
it's abilities
face removal approach and GTA 14 is
available so you should download it
right now and give it a try
so in terms of conclusion Java is still
free we have put in place everything to
deliver faster and we are delivering a
faster and we haven't had Rich's feature
pipeline for the Java platform ever and
also keep in mind this year marked the
25th anniversary of Java and given that
pipeline that we have well we can't
really say that there is a bright future
for Java developers and with that I'd
like to thank you for your time